you guys want to hear a really pointless
story about the day we invented the
internet okay here we go
and if you were really about that you
wouldn't be decided on Twitter said get
a mind
what said Internet
I knew I forgot to do something sorry
guys I went to pay it but there was this
dog there who looked like he needed some
water so I went to get him some water
and I couldn't just leave him there
so there we are hanging out having fun
we decided to share an ice cream cone
like they did in Beethoven the first I
want to see if it was gross or not it is
so you forgot forgot what oh yeah sorry
I forgot to pay the bill yeah oh but I
did pay it just now hey it'll be back on
tomorrow
where are you going I'm going to the
cafe where I can finish this Twitter
battle and not be bothered and I'm going
to the library to finish watching the
opinion to finish working where I'll be
finishing my work mo would you like to
come with me it'll be free you won't
have to pay for anything no the public
library is for drug dealers and
prostitutes what is wrong with you that
is not true
it's true you're so pretentious I can't
take him she'll see sorry guys we can
have so much fun without the internet
oh hello there even moment for world
thief no ideals steel safety do you have
a moment aluminium so start oh look at
that I have a phone call no you're not
on the phone sandwich hey barista Robin
hey mo um listen my boss is here and she
said that you can't be here unless you
buy something and I see a lack of
something oh okay yeah well how much is
a coffee
450 it's it part gold I'm sorry um a
muffins only a dollar seventy-five hey
okay yeah yeah I'll take a month okay
watch it toots cause people to it this
isn't college kid this is the public
library the public library can't be
there bad what is mo no mo no hey it's
fine I can do this if you want anything
more than usual toe second it's gonna be
double price I'm gonna give my 17 pounds
Alaric okay Hubert walking a library
right now to handle this deal for the
computer I can't do traced to me
right after you won oh no that's okay
you have fun at the library I'm gonna go
home you go on all you just got here no
that's all right
enjoy your come to the lobby oh no for
the library hey remember me are you
ready to pay for that muffin yeah of
course Daniel I left my wallet in the
car you don't have a car
well then I really need to go find it
then just get it what okay please get
out
yeah you've been doing this all day bro
bruh not all day hey bird
okay no social I'll see ya follow
through bro
two hours 12 bags and dozens of
indecipherable rules later a new type of
family game was born which is how I
imagined the invention of Monopoly
probably went hi how was the library
oh the library was wonderful and
completely normal yeah you saw a drug
dealer didn't you I did he was scary
I ran that's good what is this game well
it doesn't have a name yet but Moe's up
12 points he keeps hitting the Freitas
bag which is worth the most points can i
play
yeah okay go wait did you like real
quick bro you know make this fun beard
oh look at that
really oh wait a six is that silly
that's what I'm talking about
I'm really good at this game and I'm
feel like we are acknowledging that all
connections to the outside world had
been lost but I made some new
connections at night oh yeah I'm happy
to be you guys oh you did ring hey can
we call this game the Internet
we can play it whenever Papa gets to pay
the Internet yeah that was the day we
invented the internet I mean a place for
mindless activity and good times with
friends you're so special
it's here it's here
what get it there there's a very fine I
got it
get it yeah you get it it's here